the driver who police say is responsible
for crashing into two bicyclists that
left one dead and then caused a 10 car
crash is now Behind Bars after being
released from the hospital police say 27
year old Marco Benitez faces multiple
charges including DUI resulting in death
now this crash happened on Friday night
near Flamingo and Maryland that is where
Victoria Saha joins us live to explain
how so many vehicles were involved
Victoria
well
yeah Christian police markings are still
visible today as you can see exactly
where the two bicyclists were struck and
this is all after the driver tried
escaping from a crash just up the road
it's a busy intersection by Flamingo and
Maryland Parkway
but on Friday evening traffic came to a
stop as police investigated a series of
crashes involving 10 cars and two bikes
and I heard a big bail and looked up our
and I think the woman's flying the
bicycle slide and I pushed him back and
then the guy landed up out here by the
pope Robert status this witness who did
not want to be identified says he was
out for a walk when he saw a car
speeding through the streets police say
27-year-old DeMarco Benitez was behind
the wheel of his Ford Explorer Sport
Trac truck and tried to get over the
metal he tried to push through he's
doing about a hundred police say
benitez's Ford crashed into a back of a
Kia near East Flamingo and Claymont
Street he then sped off going east on
East Flamingo where police say he hit
two bicyclists riding on the right bus
lane Benitez then drove off and crashed
into multiple cars stopped in the
eastbound Lanes by Flamingo and Maryland
Parkway of the two bicyclists hit one
died on scene a tragedy for the bicycle
Community who always fear this happening
that's at 4 000 pound vehicle that's
hurtling at these people that are are
vulnerable around the roadways and
we we stand no chance I mean no chance
when their speed and alcohol involved
the other bicyclist was taken to Sunrise
Hospital in serious condition as for the
bicyclist that died Witnesses told me it
was a woman who looked fairly young but
we're still waiting for the coroner to
release the identity reporting from the
East Valley Victoria Saha eight news now